дуже важливі видатки нова програма
завершення будівництва міжнародного
наукового центру
обсерваторія на горі Піп Іван
Чорногірський на 41 млн грн друзі Ви з
якою гори впали в нас війна який піп
Господи Піп Іван Чорногірський при всій
повазі Ну там є Вже сніг Слава Богу Піп
Іван Чорногірський стоїть вже сотні
тисяч років і буде стояти сотні тисяч
років без нас 41 млн грнь давайте
військовим віддамо оце наші гори оце
наші Альпіністи оце наші астрономи Ну ми
знущаємось от це голосування вся країна
побачить Піп Іван Чорногірський дуже
важливі видатки нова програма завершення
будівництва міжнародного наукового
центру обсерваторія на горі Піп Іван
Чорногірський на 41 млн гр